meanwhile
people who tried to donate to the
canadian truckers peaceful protesters
um
when they tried to do that the the the
website
that was taking those donations was shut
down and hacked
information about the donors was leaked
to the public
and american media has participated in
doxing these small donors let's put up
this from libs of tick tock they've got
some examples of what the media is doing
this is happening
this is a
this is not just one this is one example
we'll give you but this is this is
pretty widespread in the media right now
it says the salt lake tribune is now
using the give send go hack data to
reach out to donors who gave as little
as 50
this is harassment this is not
journalism and then we have we have the
actual screenshot a reporter who reached
out to one of these guys
who donated 50 bucks
says i'm a reporter with the salt lake
tribune your name and email address
appeared in leaked data from give send
go contributions to the canadian trucker
convoy
your name your name appeared to be
associated with a 50 donation
uh can you email or call me to confirm
this matches your records
why did you decide to donate to the
campaign
well here's a good response none of your
damn business why i donated to it
these are
just normal people giving forty dollars
fifty dollars
to peaceful protesters in canada
and they're being doxed by the corporate
media
compare again do you think anyone are
they going to be chasing down
the people who donated to the bail fund
for an attempted assassin a blm
assassin who went in tried to shoot a
jewish guy
are we gonna get any doxing of that of
those people
probably not
well what we can do and i'm glad that
this uh email was put out there with the
guys um
brian scott's a guy's name apparently uh
salt lake tribune
so we got his name i wish that his email
address was out there as well
because i'll tell you the only way that
this stops with the corporate media
doxxing and harassing regular
law-abiding people who've done nothing
wrong whatsoever
the only way it stops is if the
journalists who engage in this behavior
are docs themselves
i mean their email addresses their phone
numbers their home addresses everything
put out there
and they would deserve it
because this is the environment that
they've created and it's the only way
this stops
not just not just giving screenshots of
emails that's a good first step
but all their other information too
because these are
parasites
i mean this this is scum of the earth
we're talking about enemy enemy of the
people trump was ahead of his time in
that label
um
there were a lot of people when trump
first started calling the media the
enemy of the people
there were even a lot of people on the
right who said i don't know it's a
little bit overboard
well that's quite literally the enemy of
the people they are going after the
people just normal people and trying to
destroy their lives why
no reason just well because they don't
agree
because they have the wrong opinions
about things so we're going to destroy
their life well 40 years ago ronald
reagan saw massive inflation unlike
anything the country had ever seen
before until today in reagan's own words
inflation is as violent as a mugger as
frightening as an armed robber and as
deadly as a hitman so right now your
retirement accounts are under attack
thanks to the inflationary policies of
this administration if you've not yet
called birch gold the only people i
trust to help you diversify your 401ks
and iras into gold then you are missing
the boat actually you're treading water
without a life vest birch gold has your
life vest let them help you convert an
ira or 401k into a tax sheltered ira in
gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a-plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings all
you got to do is text walsh to 98 98.98
to get a free info kit on gold reagan
knew the biggest threat to our wealth
and you could protect your wealth now
text walsh to 98 98 98 to get your free
info kit now now this this question of
uh
whether or not the journalists who do
this should whether we should be sort of
fighting fire with fire
you know there's some on the right to
say that's not the right approach effect
someone emailed me yesterday i have the
email right here it says matt what do
you think about the conservatives saying
that we should dox the journalists who
docks the truck trucker donors isn't
that repaying evil with evil which the
bible forbids
well here's the point i want to make
it's not
okay it's fighting fire with fire
it's kind of a war of attrition
um mutually assured destruction it is
that
you know that's that's also why i would
say people who participate in cancel
culture
deserve to be canceled people who went
after joe rogan for saying naughty words
and then others went and dug through
their tweets and thought oh you use the
same naughty words
they deserve that joe rogan didn't but
they do
and that's the only way canceled culture
stops mutually a short destruction if
you if you take part in this it's going
to turn around on you eventually
right you launch your nuke the other
country is going to launch theirs and
now everybody's dead
but it's not evil with evil because only
one party is evil here
it's not inherently evil to dock someone
it's not like that's an inherently evil
act now it's it is never acceptable to
engage in an inherently evil activity
even if you have good intentions because
that's ends justify the means and that's
that's morally wrong
but doxing someone is not inherently
evil i mean there's nothing inherently
evil about putting someone's information
out there necessarily is it inherently
evil to put a child rapist on a registry
that's certainly a form of doxing
um
so you
but i think we'd all agree that it's not
so your motive and reason matter
it's evil to dock someone who gives 40
to a crowdfunding campaign for peaceful
protesters that's evil
because they've done nothing wrong and
they don't deserve that treatment
there's no benefit there's no good
to come of doing this to them
doxxing journalists who behave this way
is different
because they have done evil they are
evil and they have to pay for it
in order to stop this in the future
it's justice for them number one
but also it's the only thing that would
that has any hope of putting an end to
this whole
vicious cycle
well i hope you enjoyed that clip for
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content